let's bring it back home you're talking
about you know the the enemy's domestic
well let's talk about what's happening
here in the US we got this story from
the Daily Mail Tucker Carlson claims
Barack Obama enjoyed smoking crack and
having gay sex nobody reported ahead of
the 2008 election did he actually claim
it or did he say maybe this is no he
said outright yes how does he know he
said the campaign would remove anybody
who brought it up in 2008 even because
he said a guy came forward Larry
Sinclair and said I'll sign an affidavit
and he did I'll do a lie detector and he
did he said that he smoked crack with
Barack Obama and they had sex that was
obviously true Carlson was referencing
the claims made by a convicted felon
Sinclair at the national Press Club in
2008 while Obama was running for
president he said nobody reported on it
due to threats from the Obama campaign
quote nobody reported it not because
they were squeamish about sex or drugs
but because the Obama campaign said
anyone who reports on this gets no
access to the Obama campaign so they
didn't report on it the amount of lying
in the media about it was unbelievable
this happens all the time up and down
government Sinclair who has spent time
in prison for forgery fraud and larceny
alleged that Obama who was then a
senator bought and smoked cocaine I
think it was crack before having sex
with him well I will I will add that um
Obama has not particularly good taste in
men if that's true
well you know I mean and he has good
taste in women
well look I mean yeah I gotta be honest
like if you if you put Michelle Obama
next to this guy she's got beautiful
eyes
let's be real I mean this is this guy's
54 now and he was a lot younger back
then uh but let's be serious there was
that letter they actually have it they
have something here on the story look at
this I don't know what this is they say
former president Barack Obama's gay sex
fantasy was revealed in a newly obtained
1982 letter to his ex-girlfriend so we
know in 1982. he was 21 I think he was
writing about how he wanted to bang
dudes and you know hey more power to him
man I just think it's historically
significant if we can if we can say that
um Barack Obama not only uh the first
black president uh or not entirely white
president was also a gay man who smoked
crack one more reason to give the guy to
give the guy grief he was the first LGBT
president yeah and didn't even have the
cojones to admit it don't be big and he
lied he lied when he was running he was
against gay marriage when he was running
yeah and then he came out uh once he got
elected so he lies to get elected hides
the fact he's LGBT and then he comes out
oh God more reason to hate on him thanks
Obama I don't think Tucker's lying but I
don't think that taking the word of a
fraudster this guy's a convicted
convicted for fraud and he's the one
that's saying that he had sex with
Barack I it's witness testimony it's one
guy's testimony so why would Tucker make
the claim that it's true just because
that's the lie detector exactly not
admissible in court yet Tucker claims
it's true because the guys because it
makes good headlines Tucker's saying
what he Tucker's reporting what he heard
well he's he could have said that a guy
told him but instead he came out and
said it's true I don't know I mean I
didn't did he actually say it's true so
I mean maybe this could confirm the the
Big Mike rumors though
I don't know if that I don't know lie
detectors can be admissible as long as
both parties agree to them okay the
issue is more so that there someone will
contest it so they're generally not used
but even still I mean it doesn't it
doesn't matter like the people that
don't like Barack Obama this is only
going to be stuff for them to go ahead
and make jokes about the people that
like Barack Obama they're not going to
care it doesn't matter
we know we know that he would lie about
you know his policies to get elected I
mean that's that's he's we already know
what kind of person he is he's already
in and out of office he's already killed
yeah children that's the thing if you
really want to stay focused on what he's
done wrong I feel like this is a red
herring there's no reason well nobody's
focusing on what he's done wrong there's
absolutely no appetite to bring him up
on charges for anything so there's no
point other than being like hey don't
forget if news does come out for some
reason it sticks and it's like Barack
Obama killed American citizen nobody
cares but let's say for some reason the
story does pop whatever a new one comes
out that Obama mentioned another drone
strike Obama would come out and all the
news would be like Obama's about to give
a press conference oh I wonder if it's
about the allegations and the drones and
he's gonna go my fellow Americans I'm
gay and then that's it and then everyone
goes wild yeah
yep that I mean that's the thing for me
it's like it's it's it's funny you know
if you want them to to make jokes about
or whatever like you know poke fun at it
to to make light of it but it's not
substantially it doesn't matter it's fun
on the internet yeah exactly it's
exactly it's a funny meme it's fun on
the internet and we were talking about
this before listen if you're involved in
politics but you're not taking part in
the culture War you're dead in the water
right we talked about that on the way
here every single you know candidate for
anything Pete bootage anybody who's got
uh some kind of diverse uh identity of
any sort is gonna put that at the very
Forefront to deflect them from all their
bad policies and Obama would just do
that he'd write another Memoir you know
and everybody would go buy it and forget
all about it I don't know but I do think
things are changing right that that's uh
statistic about 12 seconds 12th grade
boys being uh or males they're adults
um skewing conservative yeah I actually
as you mentioned if you're not in the
culture where you're not in politics
exactly yeah I think we're we're we're
at heavy Market saturation for politics
it's it's becoming pop culture I mean
we've talked about this a couple years
ago politics is pop culture that's why
you get people who have no business in
politics doing political podcasts this
is why you have late night comedy it's
nothing but politics right there's no
one cares about anything else speaking
of did you see the five bit the big five
night late night hosts Strike Force Five
dude they're doing a Twitter show
together and it looks so lame
Seth uh what's his name Seth something
Myers Myers looked so miserable in that
promo it's like you couldn't even say it
with feeling I saw the clip and now I
have to start chemoing what's okay
it's got Jimmy and Jimmy Fallon looks so
annoyed with Jimmy Kimmel like those
guys do not want to be in the same room
together he's like oh my God I'm stuck
up they're getting paid 100 million
bucks tonight or whatever contract and
the studios were like you're doing we
know how to make money and generate
contact while their content while
there's no writers you're doing this
they made Stephen Colbert be like the
ringleader and the other guy's like who
is this dip like I'm not bowing down to
this guy why is he the one ring leading
this crap it's really annoying I
breaking apart
I hope so I mean Joe Rogan being the
biggest podcast is and and for a long
time and by a long shot I mean a long
long ways I mean he's got what Twice The
Daily viewership as CNN I mean it's long
form one-on-one yes it's the most bomb
awesome agreed possible format yeah you
might be bringing other people too is
cool but any disruption of a Vibe sucks
if you're really in the zone Tucker
proved it I mean he went he went free
agent and he's getting more views than
fox has ever got ever ever you learn so
much about somebody and let's be real
right so everyone's talking about this
200 million views or whatever those are
tweet views Impressions yeah I don't
like the word impression because
typically an impression implies like
when you're scrolling through an article
and there's something on the left of the
screen you don't pay attention to right
a tweet view passes by you and you look
at it as it passes you by
so it's I'm not trying to to defend you
know Impressions or whatever I'm just
trying to point out there is a subtle
difference if I'm scrolling my Twitter
feed and I'm actually looking at things
and then not interested not interested
not interested it's very different to an
ad was on the left of my screen I never
even noticed do you know how long it
needs to remain on your screen as you're
scrolling to count it might be a couple
seconds that would be in the code I
think it's three seconds okay it's
different on different sizes I'm not
entirely sure but what we do know is if
you actually look at the Hard numbers
which are available on some devices it
was around like 20 million views sure
and you look at his ratings on Fox they
they come out like Tucker did not get
200 million views he got 20 and I'm like
Wow when he was on Fox News getting
three right so now he's getting 17 more
okay you look at all the shows he's
doing he actually is getting several
million hits per episode yeah no I mean
I'm sure he's getting a lot more
especially with the president Trump
interview way more than he ever got on
Fox I mean it can't be even close well
he had like five point something was his
record you know yeah
with the Trump thing it's it was like
20. yeah it was uh I think when they
reported it was around like 18 so it's
got to be
20 to 25 by now well and I could say if
actual like people sitting down and
watching through the video listen I this
is as a as a candidate for president I I
am not and I mean I'm not out seeking
the Legacy like corporate news media I'm
seeking the big podcasters right that's
who I wanna that's who I want to go to
when you have candidates for the office
of the of the entire United States
executive branch that are seeking out
podcasts instead of the the corporate
news media the corporate news meet is
dead that's it dude this is what vivek's
plan has been too Rachel maddow's
audience elderly right and uh even even
Fox News audience they're they're a lot
older Tucker here's here's the biggest
screw-up that fox did Tucker actually
was attracting younger viewers yes he
was getting key demo viewers you look at
these other guys and they're and they're
skewing way older and that's it
they walked away from all of it yeah
what have they got left Greg got Phil
does he that's about I mean God feels
cool he's doing he's doing well he's a
younger crowd Jesse Waters took over for
Tucker but everybody just despises Fox
News I mean you look at uh um who was it
was it uh Neil Cavuto talking to Vivek
ramaswamy trying to justify the
indictments against Trump and it's it's
just laughably bad and Vivek is like no
are you nuts he's like well you know
there's all of these indictments I mean
one of them has to be real and it's like
are you okay the fox is terrible but you
know to be honest Cavuto is never like
their best personality anyway right I
haven't watched Fox other than Tucker
Gutfeld and Kennedy I haven't watched
fox in probably I don't know 10 years
Kennedy's awesome yeah I used to watch
her on MTV man so did I that girl was
awesome yeah plus uh she'd have Devon
Dave was like a regular and Spike
Spike's been on there several times too
Olivia Rondo goes on yeah Olivia Rondo
there's a lot of people that I I know
from the conservative Circle that goes
on there what's your plan man your
presidential plan uh so we we actually
we have a whole website has all our
platforms up there abolished yeah so we
I've talked about so you know much like
vivec who I think may have stolen one of
my platform points but by the way I'm
pretty sure that he stole one uh for the
debate I had never heard a presidential
candidate talk about how the federal
government subsidizes separating
families and States uh until he's he
spoke about it on the on the debate but
I do want to abolish title IV D of the
Social Security Act which is a incentive
from the federal government they give
three dollars for every two dollars
spent on child support and enforcement
programs in every state so they're
incentivizing the state to create a
visitor out of one parent
and uh because custodian apparent out of
the other parent and then if this parent
has any issues they criminalize them and
take more so we're talking three dollars
for every two dollars given that's what
they do
um and if you look since 1975 when when
Ford signed this into law uh if you look
since then the um uh amount of
fatherless homes has increased tenfold
tenfold I mean insane amount and one in
four uh kids lives and follows home now
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time